so one good thing about this course that
the students would take it this seemed
to already be aware that they something
that they need to I would say and learn
about clear language exam so because you
can see that in in in the answers to the
first kiss any idea because I start the
course by asking them some basic
questions to know where they are in
terms of what they know about color
languages and and I think most of them
the answers reflect what they would have
learned in your typical linguistic
textbooks which have been myself
critiquing so the idea that languages
are mixed languages and that make them
that make them special languages except
on languages or the idea that Creole
languages are somehow oversimplified
they are reduced languages that are
lesser than others so so that came up
with some of the answers very same time
many of them Kim Kim from the very
beginning they would share very I would
say finances in terms of understanding
that 20 which is emerged in the context
of very drastic power imbalance and as
such attitudes towards them reflect this
our imbalance and so they came ready to
critique what they had learned in the
linguistic textbooks so which to me was
was very was very heartening to start
the course with so one way that we start
by unpacking these misconceptions is by
comparing attitudes towards languages
with attitudes towards race and
ethnicity and as they get what they get
to see very quickly is that in fact
there is perhaps as much misconceptions
about language as it is about about race
so they get to see very early in the
course that language can be used as a
proxy for race though now it's impolite
to say certain things about say black
people or Asian people yet it's still
polite to say negative things about
language and then and then at that point
what we do want reduce some basic
linguistic analysis tools for them to be
able to see that in terms of new musics
structure there is nothing at all that's
inferior
three languages in fact what we what we
do from the very beginning is to show
that structurally they are patterns both
in the syntax or mythology of calamities
that are quite similar to patterns in
the syntax and history of of English or
French of Mandarin Chinese so they
quickly carry stems that empirically and
theoretically one cannot argue that
clear languages are any way less than
non calamities the same way that there
are no biological measures that would
deem black people to be inferior to
white people so they get very tender
Stan the power of this means that often
they themselves have got along in terms
of how the few different languages in
some cases in other kids just even
dialects of English say southern English
or black English their attitudes are
very demeaning towards those varieties
that have no basis in science that are
rooted in hierarchies of power and they
get to see that very quickly